hey everyone Jessica Jones season 2 on
Netflix has been released and as we're
working our way through these episodes
we're here with our first reactions is
this new season living up to the first
season how does it compare to the other
Marvel Netflix series like The Punisher
and defenders and all those guys will
any TV show be better than iron fist yes
every everything welcome to new rock
stars news our deep dive into all the
biggest stories this week so we're also
gonna talk about these new Avengers
infinity war photos that were that were
released and what they tell us about the
movie's plot uh as well as discussion
about what's going on on the Walking
Dead why is the best storyline from the
comics we'll talk about that I'm Erik
Bosse joining me at this table are Boyd
Garrett hello Phillip Molina
hello yeah there it is was waiting for
it to turn Sam bash everybody has
everyone doing great these are my
favorite people to talk about these
things with at this table it's a dream
come true for me and I can't wait to get
started talking about our top story
Jessica Jones season 2 and as I said
we're still working our way through this
season but all of us here have seen at
least the first episode so I thought
let's share our thoughts on it now for
those of you watching don't worry this
is gonna be a completely spoiler free
zone here we don't even know what
happens at the end of this season
so we couldn't spoil you if we tried if
we wanted to and for those of you
watching yeah do it to us every you do
everyone a favor and keep those comments
spoiler free to write at least like tag
or tag them say spoiler thing at the top
of n you know don't be d okay so we've
seen the first episode let's talk about
things that we liked so far uh sorry I
got excited the show is actually from
episode 1 and that's all I've seen
because I'm there's I got away I got I'm
gonna marathon it in one day so it's
gonna be it's gonna be a blast but so
far it's it's been solid Krysten Ritter
I'd really missed her performance as
Jessica Jones and also she's doing more
there's more that they could to play
around with it especially she's dealing
with right off the bat the consequences
of season 1 finale and
offenders what happened in there and
they don't even need to talk about
happening with defenders because
critically and fen was it wasn't the
most well-received show so that's fine
as mattered they all have to do is just
say it happened and we can move on from
there and now there's a different person
like people actually know who she is
which is kind of it's weird because even
in comics people don't really know who
jessica jones is she's a PA you're not
supposed to be eyes aren't opposed to be
famous you know it's like so I enjoy
that new technique which would be a
great plot point for an episode in the
show but but that's been great and
Tricia it's good to see her back or just
Trish I like her deal so far and I'm
excited to see how they play out the IgH
storyline
yeah they set up in season 1 yeah like I
think the big success of the first
season was having the villain kind of
unknown for the first few episodes and
we're having that back again which I'm a
big fan of we don't know who this or
what this entity is but it it's kind of
like it's super super powerful and the
thing about Jessica Jones yeah she's
like such a badass doesn't feel anything
she has quickies in toilet stalls but
it's really kind of nice to know that
she's scared about the thing that is her
most powerful aspect the thing that you
know is the thing that you know she's
gonna be fine she's strong but that
might not be enough in this instance and
it's a new level of vulnerability that
is seeping into her so I dig that but
I'm noticing with Trish now she is
Australia grateful bride yeah very good
accent is really not great and it's
grinding my gears a bit
that's my impersonation of Rachel you
gotta do yours man yeah I don't hear
these things I got a bad ear for accents
that's like you know because what I mean
tell me if I'm wrong but I have heard
that Australian and British actors do
their American accent is just based off
of television and films that they watch
and I'm just used to hearing that as the
truth
I mean sometimes
it just this one feels a little bit
force it feels like she didn't really
perfect the American accent yeah
sometimes you just can't tell yeah yeah
so tell with this one I like but I love
doing great things
yeah they took over every movie ever and
they're all doing the right thing like
everyone you love including your mother
is unfairly yeah although most of the
Marvel characters are played by
Australia's own good you nailed it thank
you I'm really agree with what Sam was
saying about I'm a big fan of you know
what defenders happen don't worry about
it like that's that's not gonna be what
this season's about but that is also
part of what I love and about this show
is I think it's of all of the properties
the most grounded and we're already
talking about the Hell's Kitchen Bunch
that's their name right the Hell's
Kitchen yeah they all are supposed to be
the street-level heroes and that's
supposed to make us feel more grounded
but I think the fact that Jessica Jones
always had like a different gig being
the P I kind of made this show feel like
it you know other than the fact that
kilgrave had mind powers it was kind of
just a realistic thriller well he
doesn't do practice much law in in
season one doesn't he he practices the
street law don't use the head but but
she practices the street while actually
a bunch but the fact that they're not
only so grounded with her reality which
I always love that dose in the Marvel
Universe remind us like okay sure
guardians are out there but down here
people behave really but then also
psychologically the to me it's another
take on a Superman and Man of Steel
breaking Zod's neck and how everyone was
like you can't do that Superman would
never kill and maybe it's it's a big
problem there because of the iconic
character I would never kill and yadda
yadda but here like you said people
don't really know Jessica Jones as much
so to really get into its exact same
thing she snapped someone's neck but
that haunting hurts like I've actually
killed someone using my supposed
like how is that gonna gonna change how
she uses the exact same gift later
supposedly for good it's like I could
also snap your neck like that's always
like a go to that can show for so
psychologically it's such a grounded
show - yeah and you can't like because
of kilgrave's abilities of being able to
influence people it's not like a
physical thing so it's really easy for
people probably to forget what he could
do or if you'd never experienced it it
doesn't sound believable super strength
you see it because they saw Avengers it
makes more sense but saying that someone
can do could literally make you do
whatever they want like it's easy for
that to get kind of mixed up and she's
already such an unlikable person like we
love her because we have it she is the
character and we're told - she's yes but
me I mean like she's there's points when
you're not you don't like her just in
general but like you're supposed to but
I get why as the general populace would
be like no she snapped someone's neck
with one arm like that's that's insane
and also what also one fun thing that
like you saying that it's grounded
there's elements of like bigger ideas or
more supernatural I guess just to use a
broad term supernatural aspects of the
MCU kind of starting to seep down to
street level because it would be like in
normal comics like crazier things happen
in smaller towns and like that's what
makes it kind of fun so I'm glad that
you're kind of getting hints of that in
season no - yeah it's a the character a
deep cut character that no one really
spoilers but just like weird that he
gets to be in in a TV show but anyways
yeah looking comparing Jessica Jones to
the other Marvel Netflix characters
she's personally my favorite just
because I think Krysten Ritter is the
most comfortable in this characters skin
like I think anytime you watch any actor
take over like a superhero character
who's there kind of doing that balance
of trying to do fanservice in their
heads but also trying to like bring this
human to life and Krysten Ritter just
from the get-go
took over this character and just made
it someone who's like funny and is like
an equal-opportunity a violent person it
might say an equal-opportunity right now
I'm thinking and usually doesn't get
paired with violence right she doesn't
matter whether it's someone who is
coming to or who has like a real sob
story that she should go after or
someone who is just like someone who
doesn't really care about she if they
are trying to manipulate her and use her
for something that she doesn't feel
she should be used for she will scare
the hell out of him
and we see that in the opening scene of
season 2 it reminded me a lot of us some
of these scenes in season 1 when
someone's trying to like use her as a
pariah for what happened in the incident
in the Battle of New York
she'll trash their place you know and to
me that makes her such a likeable fun
character and a really believable
character to someone who's haunted and
doesn't want people using her for their
own personal ends and that's one thing
I've really loved about her right and
the mystery I kind of have going into
season two is as much as I love her and
I'd watch you know 13 episodes fine of
Christian Ritter's take on his character
is how much did Jessica Jones need
kilgrave in that first season he was one
of the best villains we ever saw and and
he's we'll see how much I the trailer
kind of hinted that he might come back
in some ghostly form but how much does
this show need his presence and he says
his his evil is a new dimension of the
evil that we've never seen before so the
first half of like the first few
introductory episodes of just Jessica
Jones I was like cool now we know who
his character is and then I thought it
was about five hours of her being angry
and mopey and down and that came
actually quite exhausting to watch time
and time again and it was the
introduction and the discovery of like
kilgrave that that first moment where
you discover his powers how he makes
this girl kill her parents and you just
like what the hell yeah these guys that
you can be as strong as you want you
can't stop that I loved that that
complete imbalance and I found myself
far more invested in kilgrave than I was
Jessica and I feel like he really stole
the shower when he carried the show
completely and now it's kind of back
again where there's more layers of her
being angry and a entity I've killed
someone now people think I'm a killer
and now people call me a freak because
they know about the power I could wear
back and I don't see this is a bad thing
I don't think that all the glory in the
whole show has to ride on the hero you
look at Black Panther
you look at doc night like the villains
that steal the show and that provide
just as much excitement and almost
integrity to the character as the hero
does that that's a lot for me and at the
moment we just see a guy who can jump
and literally twist a neck but um we
don't like him shrouded in mystery yeah
that's fine yeah
yogurt yeah I think if I were to get me
its heart was so early in the season
it's not really fair to like talk about
gripes so much but I think this is my
general gripe with all of it most
Netflix show specifically the the
Netflix Marvel shows is the pacing right
so they have 13 episode seasons and
without fail every single one of these
series there's always three or four
episodes that I felt they were kind of
dragging their feet on and there are
times there's this is like a 52 minute
episode I watched episode 2 is why I
won't talk about the plot stuff but like
I felt like both those episodes could
have been one episode and there are
reasons for this Netflix wants us to
spend more time watching Netflix shows
and on the showrunner side of it they
this is a staff of writers who will get
paid more and get and get a longer
production schedule if they shoot 13
episodes versus do what stranger things
did and shoot 8 episodes I'm so good on
the content creator side we're gonna get
more episodes but from the consumer side
I you know I think we could have paced
this episode more more pace as season
all these seasons more quickly so we can
get right to the mr. right to the story
and keep things moving at a more brisker
pace but one like negative thing for
like MCU movies were like black panther
you got like a little bit of this you
don't get time for characters to ever
breathe and like to get to know them and
they're like okay fine we'll do the
opposite we'll give you like 13 hours
with one character and you get to know
them and then you realize that like when
the writers sat down to like a whole we
can actually take these characters that
people don't know and actually make them
more interesting than the characters
they're already like attached to like if
you watch The Punisher people don't know
Mike Rowe and Mike if I said that to a
normal person I don't know who that is
but in the show he was really
interesting they built on his family and
you got to know his family the Punisher
became like a father figure for all
those kids and for like the wife it was
a support system like it made the show
more compelling and you actually turned
the punisher into a human but like it
you it's a problem because you don't
have usually enough writing to make
these main heroes
more likeable for 13 hours I don't know
I there there's a it's a give-and-take
and they gave them too much so they gave
them too much to work with like it's my
point so good I mean they're using the
same formula of have their own origin
stories fleshed out these characters
then bring them together but I think
when you have instead of an hour and a
half or two hours you have 13 hours it's
just like bringing tea like yeah I have
more balance haven't don't put the
spotlight on one for so long so yeah I
think yeah we need more quality yeah
quantity even defenders that felt like
too long and that was 8 episodes so it's
like why did that what happened if we're
we're doing grapes right yeah ok so I
think my my issue has kind of what you
guys are talking about a little bit it's
the pacing but I think it's I get a
little more specific with it I don't
think we need her origin story I don't I
I think season one didn't need her
origin story and we were so attached to
what was going on so why do we need it
in season 2 I think that's kind of like
a trope that is like well we got to find
out how they got that way and it's like
you know what it was a fun mystery
whatever whatever it was yeah one and
like they there they had to really think
it out made there changing the version
in the comics but if you read alias like
there's not at least especially the
initial alias run that really inspired
the show it's short it deals with the
purple man and that's kind of like the
story so they do have to like figure out
a new way to do this season and I agree
that they could do it faster I wish they
would do just say you know what eff it
forget the fact that you know how we've
done comic book shows let's turn this
into a freak of the week show
I think it'd be super interesting to do
law and order Jessica Jones unit Buffy
the yeah essentially and it's just like
she solves the the mystery she kicks
some ass and there's a season long big
bad there you go but I mean are we
seeing too much of that or is this what
we crave no I saw were so well it works
I you touch one interesting thing with
origins story I've had enough of origin
stories right like for some reason we
have right side we want to get to the
bottom like we have an investigative
yeah come on guys let's go more on this
no there's this idea of like we want to
we want to figure out where every
villain and where every hero began and I
don't know I think we saw whatever your
thoughts on the Star Wars prequels are I
think that is a perfect example of like
I didn't need to know where Darth Vader
came from I had plenty of information
from the original timeline granted the
prequels gave us so much great stuff and
this is just where we podracing there's
so many examples of where we look at
where hero came from so Louis Star Wars
story Hannibal rising like sometimes
characters just work Erik thank you
start in the middle of them look up
stories begin where they begin for a
reason because they're more exciting to
start in the middle and I don't know
that's my little rant snape snape yeah
like a second
I wonder how is worse on the bug Louis
like smoking was it magic smoking what
happened I will say just to counter it I
like because there is literally no more
comics after they did like they did a
few more and then she becomes mom for
like cage and her get together and then
there's like nothing to know she has a
new ish new comic that I really like but
it deals with purple man again so it's
just like and it's it's the either
closing the chapter on purple man that's
what the story is and you're like I
don't know if you could tell any more
stories after this in the in the comics
it's way more open-ended left with them
so they did kind of need to wrap it up
here
they wrapped it up real quickly yes and
it was a bit of a bummer I but and I am
excited for the origin because actually
allows for the story the writers to open
up the MCU more and include different
characters like wizard I'll just say the
name you know I if you need to look if
you want to look him up by that name you
probably don't know what he does but uh
but like you have you have opportunities
now to play with more characters and
Jessica Jones playing off those
characters will is what made her so
interesting so you and you can take
b-list d-list Z Lister's and write them
however you'd like and they couldn't be
a new kill great but they could be a
good foil for Jessica Jones and her bad
attitude that blends in
you having the you know the big new
baddie every episode as well so that's a
great pitch for the defenders because
you could have Heroes for Hire like
Daniel Rand and Luke Cage they're doing
like P I work but they team up with
Jessica Jones and you have Matt on the
legal side of it so they're all like
coming together but at the end they got
the dragon bones then dragon bones at
the end is tracking bones who would I
guess that yeah well let's like okay so
we're done with the first episode it's
you know they laid out some plot lines
and some characters are discovering new
things about themselves what are we most
looking forward to as we head towards in
the next 12 episodes our game back for
the Luke Cage all right I miss Luke and
Luke's with Claire I know but like I
want them together because they have a
little baby named Danielle and it's
really sweet that's gonna be super weird
now cuz in the comics she's named after
Danny ran because he died and now it'd
be like yeah or Danielle after my my
best friend from that dragon time
recently yeah you're a good role model
for my daughter yeah I'm gonna name you
it after her yeah after him but yeah
it's I would love to see the relation
because they were really good in season
one even in defenders like Eve were like
hell Rocky that was Jessica Jones with
Matt was great and then her with Luke
that was great I don't care you know
everyone's to be scared to stand up to
them or to regulate them and because he
was strong as well he was just like boom
you know and she met an equal not only
in a physical capacity but like in an
emotional capacity and I really liked
that yeah he ain't gonna mess around for
me I really love the supporting
characters on the show carrie anne moss
as jerry Hogarth yeah she is one of the
like best actor scores that they got and
all these Netflix Marvel series so I'm I
always love to see what you don't like
foggy Nelson from the mighty Doug thing
Dave
but I without spoiling it seems like
she's a very interesting subplot this
season that allows her to really show
how great of an actress she's going
she's going hey whose guy's got do we
have like tears like twitch can you give
my Bieber that was a good one was it
good
no I she's gonna go through the ringer
because she's she's not a good person no
she's not a don't even don't even she
she's not a good person so I'm excited
to see more of her and Malcolm the he
had a pretty interesting arc in season
one until he became boring and then
defenders he did nothing and but now I
like him as this like no nonsense like
assistant to him to Jessica where it's
like yeah she's gonna fire me but
whatever I got I'll be back tomorrow and
like she's there trying to help with our
alcoholism and it's just like Red Bull
and I'm like I'm a hypocrite to talk
about this but if like every time she
goes for a drink and she literally grabs
like like using it to that level she's
gonna run to the hospital even faster
because she's gonna have like a harp
yeah I turn around just real quick Sam
is obsessed with Red Bulls been drinking
coffee but less thanks everybody uh but
no like I I'm excited
also like supporting characters cuz
she's like let's see here actually yeah
yeah that's what I'm looking for though
forward to there being a little bit more
of is I I want to be like okay so you're
gonna put up or shut up yeah yeah okay
yeah and there's without spoiling
anything see episode two really as an
interesting storyline that is you know
okay so a lot of these episode all this
season was wrapped before the lot of the
recent current events have been coming
out that related to this current events
and the meaty movement the Harvey
Weinstein yes and all these other things
that are they
we finally coming out but there is a
very very interesting storyline that is
relate to that with Trish that happens
in season two and I'm very excited to
see how this whole season responds to
this new movement that I mean you could
even call Jessica Jones a bit season one
a bit before it's time and you could
argue that it did a lot to start to
bring this more to the forefront so I'm
excited to see how season 2 you are very
excited superhero world 2 because these
conversations are not happening enough
but let us know what your thoughts about
Jessica Jones season 2 in the comments
below we're gonna be watching every
episode throughout this weekend so so
we'd love to hear your thoughts
Jessica jonesing Malcolm and yeah well
the more videos in the pipeline about
this new season so keep an eye out for
those talk about more the more that
later but let's move on to this week's
trivia question and let's stay in the
theme of just a good show okay so here
is our trivia question in the first
season of Jessica Jones
Jessica refers to the Hulk as quote the
big green guy
what nicknames does she give to Captain
America okay so yeah these are probably
these little Winx that they make to the
MCU they refer to it as the incident
here we go all of our answers are in
later in the show we'll reveal the
answer to the trivia question and the
closest answer as decided by our judges
will do our sign off goodbyes at the end
of the video and do it whatever dumb
boys our new character or fake American
accent they're trying out meanwhile the
loser will have to cleverly riff on our
in other news headlines yeah and there's
been a lot of interesting news but let's
move on to we got a quick update here
guys breaking news it was announced this
week that Jon Favreau who of course
directed Iron Man he's a happy Hogan and
Iron Man movies and he directed the
jungle book the upcoming Lion King
live-action movie he will write and
produce a new live-action Star Wars
episodic series for Disney's upcoming
streaming service Oh he joins all these
other people were making Star Wars stuff
last Jedi director Rian Johnson will get
a
trilogy of star wars movies he's gonna
make Game of Thrones showrunners David
Benioff and DB Weiss they're gonna
loosen who separate Star Wars series of
films JJ Abrams is doing episode 9 so
yeah
Jon Favreau is no okay moving on to our
next topic here Avengers infinity war
released some very interesting photos to
Entertainment Weekly as part of an
in-depth feature for the film the
article and photos are full of big
reveals about this movie's story and
characters so let's take a look at these
photos and break down all the details
you need to know and yes spoiler warning
in case you don't want to know anything
about infinity war but be honest guys
okay let's take a look at this first
photo
it shows Santos on the ruins of that
planet that we've seen in the in the
past trailers now we've speculated that
this could be Zander but now Marvel
Studios confirmed that this is the ruins
of Thanos his homeworld Titan Titan is
one of the moons of Saturn it's where
Thanos was born to a race of eternals
before becoming an outcast becoming
obsessed with war and death now in this
movie it sounds like nanos is bitter
from Titan getting devastated by war and
he sees himself as a savior to the good
half of the universe aiming to destroy
the threatening and imperialist half and
I'm guessing earth is in the bad half
now look more closely at this image it
looks like Danis is using the Infinity
Gauntlet to clutch this big moon and
this guy behind him Kevin Feige
confirmed this in a quote that they
enosis grabbing the moon guys we're
gonna see Thanos Chuck a moon and iron
man like spike at a football he's names
Grogg sports references I can't believe
they've never brought that back
[Music]
let's move on to another photo here
showing rody joy named cap and black
widow rody notices wearing some techie
leg braces that allow him to stand
upright following his injury in Captain
America Civil War speaking of which it's
interesting to see these heroes on the
same side again considering yeah they
were definitely recently beating the
piss out of each other at that Airport
in Germany now according to the article
all of these heroes end up in Wakanda in
an effort to protect vision cap decides
to move him there because really let's
be honest his best defended location on
earth it's never been invaded most
people know about it the article also
says that Thor and rocket are in Wakanda
as well with Orion a new version of his
hammer a battle axe that we now know the
name of Stormbreaker yeah a lot easier
to say - meow meow and storm breakers
cool it's got an axe on the back of the
hammer like that's automatically way
cooler so yeah
for everyone that says we can 3do Owen
Wilson sounds all yeah just real quick I
just like that someone pointed out that
you know poor war machine we had to go
through a lot of rehab really work on
that spine but meanwhile in Black
Panthers know you got a spine injury
we'll fix it that's the face he would
make wouldn't figured it out too he'd be
like yeah oh you can just fix bones you
guys must have gone way back oh you just
met these new photos also include new
looks a duck strange dark long and
banner and solo shots of Sheree and low
key but the third one I want to look at
is this great shot of Peter Parker surf
in the side of a school bus now I'm
assuming this in the trailer we saw him
on his school bus looking out at the
window I'm assuming this is part of that
scene what's going on Sam no longer
looks like this that's sunshine that's
when you go outside for long periods of
time that's the vitamin D kids you're
gonna need that drink more water now
that kinda but if you're curious what
sureties wearing there it says lettuce
the taste of sadness which I need to get
new one of those but at first I was
wondering if Peter like climbed out of
the window as the bus was driving up to
go swing away in action to investigate
that cue ship but looking closely look
at the bottom it kind of looks like I'm
wondering if the bus is even on asphalt
there doesn't look like Sienna flying or
floating yeah somebody's throwing a bus
goes off a bridge that gave out I don't
know the window shut so good so wait he
ended his hands inside of the window and
it shut it's got finger holes it's like
a bowling ball
to be fair his fingers are sticky okay
I've been here I also like that he's
bringing back fossil cuffs little
leather cuff mm has to be with with the
but no I wore him in 2008 his personal
history don't want his origins webs
until eight years later whenever that
takes place I'm still mad about this
timeline thing still in school he's a
teacher well lastly we got to talk about
the magazine's cover there was 18
different covers when one of them
teacher Tony starts new Iron Man armor
upgrade this new design is for
appendages emerging from his back lot
okay now it's now confirmed that this
new armor is being referred to as
bleeding edge we've been speculating
about this for a while and a recent
promo we actually saw his armor weaving
over his neck and shoulders it's similar
to the bleeding edge in the comics
actual in the comics that emerges from
it so much just like I like your tweet
about it whatever that it was just the
wind guys from Venture Brothers no one
else responded to that so I didn't think
it was funny
it hit like on it I just laughed in real
life yeah now there's four things that
first reminding me of the the Waldos of
the iron spider armor the glass is like
four appendages
actually these are confirmed as rocket
boosters by
maybe he's propelling himself through
space maybe that's how he ends up on
Titan cuz we saw Tony Stark and then I
which is a longtime nuke powered or I
don't even think with like a Doctor
Strange could just like destroy his
brain to make yeah now guys infinity war
is servi or did serving up a lot of
great action I read to shaping it's
serving it's shaping up to be the
longest MCA movie ever two hours and 27
minutes yes the Russo brothers have
promised it will connect all 18 MCU
movies that came prior whatever that
means
you guys that all concern than it being
or might be biting off more than it can
chew
100% it's only 22 characters when you
look at the lineup it feels like
it just keeps going going I wish Civil
War it had 22 years 18 covers it's like
what four didn't yeah and it's too small
to be for like nerdy stuff there was a
cover of Entertainment Weekly they had
Thanos on it by himself and it's sold
like that isn't that weird like as a
comic as people start as a comic fans
it's just like that's the character they
got featured and then people were like I
gotta buy that because that purple guy
is someone I want to go see in theaters
punch that guy I mean the red number
grimace rip grimace yeah I mean I'd buy
that cover of Entertainment Weekly yeah
it's it's crazy Marvel is changing the
game with how films are being made we've
never seen this before we've never seen
cinematic universe this is not a movie
this is an event this is the Super Bowl
of yeah it might feel like ready player
one you know what I mean in that like a
revisiting of like okay so for us ready
player one I mean I know we're all 19
but ready player one like revisits a lot
of the things that we grew up with and
like we're so excited to think about
kids who are you know 18 younger than us
basically but like really young kids
their youth is Marvel movies it's 18
years that's from birth to 18 you know
I'm like that's that's in saying they're
gonna revisit all the movies that they
grew up with that's so cool yeah just
like well let us know what you think
about this new Stark armor and thanasis
moon toss and the general epic scale of
this movie I'm curious to hear what you
guys think in the comments below and a
reminder to subscribe to new rock stars
for more updates and analysis adventures
infinity war an all Marvel movie
coverage thanks everybody
another quick update before we move on
Kristen Wiig has been confirmed to play
the villain cheetah in the upcoming
Wonder Woman Sol is exciting Wiig is of
course better known for comedic roles
like s and Allen bridesmaids
Ghostbusters but she did play a very
very dark role in last year's Darren
Aronofsky film mother that I don't know
if anyone saw of it boo me she proved
that she can tow the line between funny
and terror
and maybe that's what she was cast real
work do we know how much cheetah is the
villain in the movie it's confirmed yeah
like that like the primary villain or a
villain
okay a villain I can be on board with I
[Applause]
like that yeah okay moving on to our
next story The Walking Dead's recent
seasons have seen a major turning point
in the show with the arrival of Jeffrey
Dean Morgan as the villain negan who
leads the Savior's and an all-out war
against Rick's forces and Robert Kirkman
Robert Kirkman's Walking Dead comics
this is one of the best most exciting
storylines but when it comes to the
adaptation on the show fans have been
less pleased ratings for the show have
declined to same what like 20 20 million
a week to like 19 or is it really bad is
it it's best and more sizeable than that
yeah it's still like the number two most
watched show but it's it's but I think
we should break down some of the key
differences between the show and the
comics and I have some questions for you
guys about adaptations in general so you
know hopefully we can like get to the
bottom of what's going on here I thought
you meant nanny 911 one that hasn't been
on the air for a while okay the first
major difference is the overall presence
of negan in the comics negan's presence
looms over everything it really feels
like it's a one-on-one between negan and
Rick but on the show jeopardy Morgan
feels a lot more like a supporting
character he has appeared in less than
half of the episodes in the past two
seasons that's significantly less than
the other series leads who don't really
matter to the plot now this may be
because Jeffrey Dean Morgan is really a
big-time actor he probably costs a lot
more to the network per episode
meanwhile Stephen OGG who plays negan's
lieutenant Simon has really kind of had
to fill in as negan second half he's
done a fantastic job but the tag-teaming
has and might been in resulted in two
half measures of good villains rather
than one full measure of negan that he
is in the comics
all the sans negan episodes bring us to
our second adaptation difference the new
communities like the scavengers and
Oceanside which really don't play a role
in this stage in the comics the
scavengers is a new creation for the
show now both of these colonies just
come off as places on a map really with
their own quirks rather than real
societies that behave the way real
people would Kirkman established that
world building so well for the hilltop
in the kingdom but at any time i nepo so
does that notion sign in the landfill is
just kind of there's no sense of stakes
now another adaptation issue is the role
Carol and Daryl play on the show as
opposed to in the comics now Daryl isn't
even in the comics but Carol's character
is significantly changed from Kirkman's
version into one of the most badass
characters on TV really now the problem
is because neither of them are part of
the all-out war storyline in the comics
the show has kind of been forced to
invent new ways for them to participate
which too often has left them inactive
like Daryl spent half a season in a
prison cell Carol spent a full season in
a freaking cottage doing nothing yeah
but at least the show hasn't killed him
off
right which is the other major
adaptation issue fans are confused about
this season saw the death of Rick's son
Carl which does not happen in the comics
at this point and in fact Carl goes on
to be a very interesting character in
storylines after this war maybe the show
was just ready to part ways with actor
Chandler Riggs and reassigned that
cooler future storylines to new
characters that they want to create
now while losing fan favorite actors
like Steven Yeun who played Glenn and
Michael Cudlitz who played Abraham that
might have been harder on viewers the
death of Carl really felt like another
departure from the comics that just
robbed us of scene the cool guy he would
turn into and another example of the
show slowing down a fast-paced war in
the comics now I know you guys aren't as
a huge Walking Dead obsessives as I am
but I'm curious to know when adapting
anything from comics to screen what do
you think is the most important thing to
get right it's the characters but the
root of it it's it's if you can make the
characters as relatable as they are when
you read a book and you can get in like
the head of the character you can
understand their motivations and that
doesn't mean like because we talked
about origins early doesn't mean like
boiling them down to that and you work
your way up to getting to where they're
at it's just just give us a frame of
mind like a
their deal is and you could just move
forward from there that for me that you
get hurt too many times see you get like
went like like they for me like we
brought up man is still earlier with
like when they snap gods and exploits
that has nothing to do with Superman at
all there's no part of what people like
about that character in what happened in
Man of Steel he's just a depressing dude
he's just sad and while that is
interesting to think that if you're a an
immigrant from space and you're the only
one of your kind you'll never be able to
meet them again you have to choose to
kill the only other person you know from
your own race it's interesting but it
didn't capture anything that we care
about in Superman so it's like that's
for me that's what matters when it comes
to an adaptation if you can boil down
that when it comes to the rest of the
story you just adapt it and try to make
it good I think really happen I mean so
well done and sometimes you go to quit
while you're ahead I think five is
usually nice arounded yeah it makes room
on the Shelf where you get the box set
like panicking and stretching out these
characters you know trying to make
things work the hardest part about The
Walking Dead having such a dedicated fan
base is the writers taking on the
feedback while also doing what's right
and I think sometimes like what the fans
want so much can affect the storyline
and then people like oh you're just
pandering now so it's really like a hard
balance and I have no idea if they're
doing a good job or not it's gonna hard
to know if anyone for anyone to know if
they're doing a good job or not
including the people working on the show
because yeah at some point you're just
trying you're trying to figure out
exactly what the audience of the show is
is it just the fans who know the comics
is there a separate fan base which I
honestly think there is if the so many
people were upset by Glenn's death it
shows that there are more people
watching this show than people just read
the comics because yeah Glenn does die
in the comics it is a critical turning
point there it's a narrative reason for
him to die but people got so attached to
Stephen Yun's portrayal of that
character and when he left the show it's
something they did lose something that
they have not replaced yet and I am one
of the move I think the minority of
viewers who I think Carl's death was
justified and I mean no offense to the
actor I think they can get more
interesting characters I unfortunately I
just don't think the way maybe there was
a disconnect between the writer
and Chandler Riggs that just was not
working out and maybe they felt it too
maybe they felt that that actor was
ready to move on and I think they could
take that really cool future Carl
storyline and apply it to Rick's
daughter you know or Enid they won't
because here's the thing when again
staying with for a second a successful
comic book adaptation there's I would
say three major things that that come to
mind about the success of any story in
general but separately you have your
character arc right like what does your
character gonna go through how are they
gonna change what are they going to
learn by the end if your plot arc which
is literally what's gonna happen this
story how to keep it exciting something
climactic in the middle something a
satisfying resolution at the end and
then this one element that I think the
Walking Dead TV show loses all the time
and it's just as simple as the
characters want and goals and that being
connected to the other two things so
instead where they take they'll lift a
plot arc they'll stretch the hell out of
it and they'll make it a season of the
TV show even though it's two issues of
the comic it'll stretch the hell out of
it
then they'll stretch which is you would
think is a good move a character arc
it's like okay over the course of this
whole season Rick is gonna learn you
know what he does need other people it's
like okay fine that again they did them
to up it to issues so that might be a
lot but fine we want to see him change
so we'll go with you as long as Rick has
an active actual goal for a whole season
that matches those two things like in
you know he's gonna try to go off on his
own and you know kill every walker or
something like he has like something
very specific that he's gonna try to do
and throughout the course is gonna you
know learn about needing other people
and go through some sort of plot and
that's interesting instead they do the
other two but the characters feel like
they're floating along in this story and
so you could kind of like but you should
never go to this you can jump in an
episode one jump in a middle up so jump
in there's a last episode and you've got
the whole season this because they're
dinner actually are they're never
succeeding or failing they're always in
limbo right yeah and I mean to be a bit
cynical I think when you're watching
television shows so many of these
problems can just be ignored if you
really nail the villain and jeopardy
Morgan's acting is awesome I
him in the show but in terms of how much
they use him think of so many other
shows that like our kind of divisive
right maybe like Dexter someone there's
a couple really great seasons of the
show Dexter oncotype purely because the
villain is incredible Boardwalk Empire a
Bobby Cannavale II played an amazing
character amazing villain I believe it's
season three or four there's so many of
these like you know hour-long drama
series yeah and and you can get so much
done by just letting the villain take
over the story for a season and they
have not let he can do that they have
not Unchained him he appears every
fourth episode it's like if anything I
mean as much as I love Jeffrey Dean
Morgan Steven OGG has proven he's such a
great character actor and he is captured
that kind of negan spirit in a way and
makes me wish we could go back in time
and just cast him so that you couldn't
afford to put him in every single
episode and let him be the true lead
that negan should be in this story
because it's a bit that's a reason
people love this storyline in the comics
he's such a fun cares on the cover of so
many of those and he has not been on the
cover of most of these episodes and I
think that's I think the thing that I
hopefully going forward they'll be able
to course-correct
maybe it's just a matter of AMC's
shelling out more money to the budget
well what do you think The Walking Dead
could use more of or do you think the
show is fine and maybe some of the
haters out there should just lay off
either way comment down below and a
reminder to you all to subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our recaps
analysis The Walking Dead episodes
thanks everybody now it's time to move
on to our new rock stars news tweet us
some questions I'm gonna fire them at my
co-host we have to answer them as
quickly and without hesitation as
possible is everyone ready
no hesitation here we go Amy for Sam
plain interesting one from at bested by
Adam who would you rather want to see in
a DC EU movie Charlie Hunnam is green
arrow and Katheryn Winnick as Black
Canary or Armie Hammer as Hal Jordan and
interest Elba as John Stuart dad second
one eager Silva and Armie Hammer you
know be the coolest team up ya ever
casting director in Black Canary and
Green Arrow's really good talks to play
something or mind there were rumors for
green arrow that was one of the things
that happen and maybe something else but
and he wouldn't be bad he wouldn't be
bad you got a goatee yes but he would
also be a really good Jon Stewart do a
Marvel DC cross all right for Phillips
from at SHINee verse 78 wants to know
what three sci-fi slash comic book
movies would you want to have on a
deserted island okay Dark Knight
obviously so no an interstellar cuz it's
every movie that's ever happened it's
inside of the movie interstellar and
three I'm gonna cheat and I'll record on
one VHS tape all of the DC animated
movies because those are so as cheating
at D while unstirred Lee wants to know
what is a guilty pleasure movie of yours
in his or her case they say they cannot
resist a good old national treasure but
it's so not good for this time at all it
dated terribly but I mean dances well
that's the guy yeah your mom made you
agree watching Grey's Anatomy you do
that with SVU though yeah yeah like five
or six so I never actually watched the
second half of all of Grey's the
fifteenth season where are you starting
from the beginning and then working your
way oh I don't do that yourself no it
could've been the background the pink
for me at one fj CEO says if you could
choose a fictional character to join the
new rock stars team who would you choose
mmm
I would say that's a good question I
would say mortgage just for that voice
over that voice I want to hear his voice
you want to hear his voice right
how about God and he knows all so we
won't have any more like a fact errors
like when I thought Elizabeth Banks as
Parker Posey he'd be able to correct me
right and what a boy and he might know
all the dirty gossip from the sets you
could give us behind the scenes I want
Evan from ever almighty on this sorry no
one asked me but I take Steven Carell
well thank you for sitting there
questions everybody and keep them coming
we'll see you next week on that but next
up let's take a look at what we got in
the pipeline for videos coming out on
the channel the next week course is
Walking Dead episode 11 is coming on
Sunday you'll have a breakdown of that
Sam's continuing is in series with
Captain America Winter Soldier one of my
favorite movie action movies it is so
much fun it was such a great time
watching it
boy oh boy when they said there were
errors in this movie there are a ton but
it didn't make me dislike this at all
which was awesome also gonna be doing
Jessica Jones season 2 Easter eggs very
soon so I gotta get I have bad for me to
only watch one episode so I gotta get
going yeah we'll also have some more
videos on infinity war we now that we
have this interesting origin from
Tennyson which is a new origin new
origin that they've come up it's because
maybe it's this whole idea of mistress
death and the MC is just maybe a step
too far for most Iranians it's we're
gonna do an explainer on what
thanassis new origin means how it does
relate to the comics and what it could
mean for infinity war the first part and
the second part and beyond we're also a
lot of you have been tweeting us about
the black order which is his team of
looting crony to midnight yeah so we're
gonna do another explanation on that and
more infinity war stuff so keep an eye
out for all of that okay so now comes
the time for our 15-second shoutout
where each of us says 15 seconds to
shout out plug or ramble all that
anything we want Sam why don't you start
okay I wanted to actually give a shout
out to you guys because I just went to
Emerald City Comicon and I ran into a
bunch of people and there was a very
nice artist who shook my head for a
while and he told me about how much he
enjoys new rock stars and it was and he
kept asking me stuff about you guys he
was like what do they think about this
I'm like they're not here I don't know
what to say about that but no it was
very nice to meet you guys I just
touched that twice and I I hope you
enjoy all this content and thank you for
supporting us that's great and I just
got the cool episode I am now if you
live in the last night Angeles area I'm
back on performing on comedy stages so
band before they could know my a theatre
unfortunately shut down by some
mismanagement in Chicago but I've landed
back on my feet if you'd want to go to
the second city in Hollywood on March
17th I'm doing a show there and then
immediately the next day on March 18th
at the Acme Theatre in Hollywood I'm
doing a sketch show that's so that's my
15 seconds you know yeah mine is gonna
come from the tech world I'm going nuts
for the shape scale if you're interested
in IndieGoGo type tech that doesn't
always work out and usually doesn't work
out and mostly doesn't work out this one
is a great spot you but this one that
might not work out is a scale that you
stand on and then it shoots up this like
little vertical camera and the camera
spins around you 360 and then it creates
a freaking 360 model of your body
exactly
you can like spin and manipulate and
then as you work out or lose weight or
gain weight whatever whatever your
choice right but as you can see a just
it overlays the new changes over your
body so you actually see the difference
and then it prints out a suit of what
your old body look like and you can wear
[Laughter]
how can I contribute you like it's not
gonna work out that way but check it out
the shape scale support it I've got a
lot more junkets coming up on geek balm
so I interview celebrities for my other
job and Oprah was a recent one of those
a lot of fun oh gosh did I not say my
first sentence using any actual words
[Laughter]
you know Chris Pine is a reader and
liked 20 seconds into the interviews I
thought you called me a Breda Madison
what I did to try and get that back on
track I didn't anyone little
compilations of all my fun parts and
fails in junkets yeah Jason Bateman is
in there and come on for a game Natalie
Portman whoo like like she's like making
it sound like it's for mod has a
treasure trove of interviews with
celebrities on geek balm that is just
like endless and it's like top of the
top a-list anyone get one rates really
funny interview I had a really good chat
with Oscar Isaac about this might longer
than 15 seconds I'm so sorry but running
between the set of Star Wars and
annihilation what a pro yeah also when
you meet Oprah
you know how astronauts get like a
little time of all when they look at
earth for the first time they're like
it's the pause moment you need that for
Oprah when you like meet her you're like
I didn't know and now we're talking
about very like personal things while I
was sitting there like while they were
getting ready just talking about I'm
like she's just good at doing that well
finally let's return to the trivia
question that we asked earlier just to
remind you guys what it was in the first
season of Jessica Jones Jessica refers
to the Hulk is a big green guy what
nickname does she give to Captain
America let's see what we wrote Eric
said Uncle Sam
Uncle Sam over check out his comedy
routine Sam on a beach said the guy with
the frisbee how she delivered the line
say Phillip said the human torch
the Fantastic Four fan and mod wrote
shield dude shield my dude dude okay
well the correct answer is flag waver so
the guy with the frisbee Uncle Sam the
human torch is closed
okay so I'll do our goodbyes and then
Sam's gonna have to take care of our in
other news headlines so we did a time
where mod will read the the set up the
headline Sam will have to react to the
headline and cleverly riff on it and mod
are you ready yeah I'm good to go
all right take it away mod in other news
the Joker origin movie directed by Todd
Phillips which has Joaquin Phoenix in
talked to play for the role is rumored
to featured the Joker as a failed
comedian and the ADA hey I'm a failed
comedian in the odds I was a toddlers
and tiaras could be
I thought what is that the acronym for I
don't know Tyler's and the Black Panther
kill manga actor Michael B Michael B
Jordan offered to pay the dental costs
of a girl who break her retainer while
seeing him shirtless in the movie she's
snap dead didn't we all as my joke and
number three they all broke our
retainers when he took his shirt off
turkey fat you're getting machine c19
anyway
thore actor Chris Hemsworth him
Hemsworth is in talks to star in and
then in blacks
listen to the it's coming it's coming
down the that we ever finish the show
with some integrity like helium stuff
but now nine will be his final Star Wars
movie to compose music for didn't he
retire after duel of the fates touch
right here if you're sweeter inspired
sex toy set that up the movie won best
picture the amphibian man
dildos sold out in twenty minutes unpack
smells fishy that's nice man I wish I've
made you guys proud don't patronize me
hey well you know I was proud to be here
the last anything their side were the
fish side of the face they jumped the
shock yeah yeah it's good it's just come
up with every good comeback as soon as
you walk
room yeah Eric it's a normal dildo it's
my responsibility
I'm not even gonna address I'm not gonna
dignify that with a response
he always makes fun of me when I wear
the color palette of shape of water and
and shows am I gonna do it I was gonna
do something fun and goofy for the
goodbye I wanted to but now I'm just
gonna do it in a bad Australian accent
in honor of how bad I am in Australian
accents and uh I'll do an Australian
accent doing an American accent
thank you for watching this week's
episode episode of new rock stars news I
want to thank our house Sam basher
rootin tootin are ya ever sir
Eric vas a TA vas built Melina Melina in
Maude Garrett Goering comment down below
and tweet us at new rock stars rock
stars who like this video share it
around and subscribe to new rock stars
of our deep dives and all the stuff you
love bye love the opening line for my
new book